YouTube will announce remove all pop-up
annotations On January 15 Oh kids will
never know the true joy they will never
understand how much happiness the
annotations gave they will never see
this they never understand
[Music]
this makes me so freakin angry I could
just die someone needs to pay for this
we need to hold men accountable this is
something new I've learned Sasuke
that's why Sasuke is the one that will
pay the price for this what started off
as a cute little photo of two brothers
just hanging out has now turned into
pain for Sasuke Sasuke needs to plate
Sosuke you better freaking subscribe to
PewDiePie said mr. B's you're weak
Sasuke you like souls Sasuke
damn even ninja pics oh [ __ ] damn I
think it's safe to say that dad no one
likes Sosuke that edgy little sorry
Jesus Christ I think it's safe to say
that no one likes Sasuke
he does have songs in his name though so
he can't be that bad Marge Simpson Marge
Simpson stop it you're killing him
you're killing Sosuke you're weak Sasuke
you like souls that's what you were
gonna say you dumbass shaggy from
scooby-doo goddamn what a savage oh my
god it's that girl from that enemy where
they play drums and guitar and forgot
the name why is everyone fighting Sasuke
oh wait I said it already there's of
course also that setting on this is what
you get for killing the Naruto village
the ninja village I don't remember what
the plot was maybe oh is his brother
that did it well this is what you get
Sasuke for not being good friends to
Naruto there's of course the ultimate
crossover of this someone has to do it
you know it always happens this is not a
new meme okay kids
I've been around long enough to know
that this is not the first time this
meme has made
thing Sasuke to show you the power of
flex tape
I saw your village in half damn flex
tape we'll just put the village together
in with paper bread even Brad this again
so skip I can't believe it
Brad how could you do this Brad would
never do this Brad would never do this
you will never get G fuel sponsorship
30% off enter the code PewDiePie Brad
don't make me laugh ah
subscribe to PewDiePie we're Celski dice
listen here kids I'm desperate I will
kill Sasuke I will do it I will do it
like I'm serious I'm not joking around
here I will as it was my war face if
you're not intimidated by them then I
guess you're a tough pal now everyone
just has to take it too far
everyone just have to do the one that no
one wanted to see version of this okay
alright okay I get it
okay alright okay god damn it I'm sorry
Sasuke
but that's how my fear works and
everybody knows that
why is shaggy from scooby-doo such a
goddamn savage why do I look identical
like him he's rocking the white hair
like I used to have when my power level
was stronger okay it's time to stop it's
definitely time to stop this meme gets a
four and a five and you know why you
know why you really want to know why cuz
sashka killed the annotations on YouTube
Naruto would never do this next mean
what's that oh sorry I can't I can't
hear you I got my air pods
sorry what what are you saying nan
desuka multo you could eat could I say
excuse me what did you say
have you noticed I have air pods why
does everyone have airports guys like
what the Freak is happening here
everyone has air pods like Uganda
knuckles have air pod that's how you
know maybe there's something suspicious
going on here even threatened chickens
have air pods and waves
how can everyone afford these they're
like super expensive I don't I just like
I don't like I just like I don't like I
just like I don't get it
Mark Zuckerberg had it well now you know
it's normy wave shack
hey guys I been wearing this hat this
whole episode sir I think it's time for
me to reveal my waves oh that's right
cultural appropriation oh my god
I am so sorry guys that was way out of
line this time if I get called out I
will take hundred-percent response oh
hey mr. airport you're standing in the
middle of the road be careful there
might be a Oh No
there's a man move mr. airport move oh
no he's got cars in he can't hear me
oh no do you guys get it cuz it's the
opposite of the main mean version of
Paris cynical oh dude it's King star
don't tell me keemstar got waves don't
frickin tell me oh damn those are some
waves dogs damn they have yeah respect
keemstar like even Stalin had waves I
think it's okay for white people to have
waves because Stalin had waves for
everyone saying that white people can't
have waves excuse me
stalling had waves stop putting waves on
everything huh No Asian people be like
oh [ __ ]
Martin Luther King has airwaves and
pause damn oh shoot what's his name
President Donald Trump patch the waves
this is so racism shaking my head right
now
Obama has waves dude I thought he was
dead my foreskin their pods I'm stealing
Best Buy and pogies so that's how
everyone gets a prize okay
all right do a wave check Dennis don't
do wave check it's dangerous
let's see those waves than us
goddamn that's time yeah so that's how a
nurse gets his power all right let's
check out the waves check out the weight
whoa that's some actual waves yeah the
wave airpot mean gets zero you know why
because you can buy these why why have
air pods which you can barely I mean
they're right in your face
if you really want to show ah your air
pods then why don't you get these
instead
okay virgin air pods shad Kauai suck
away nico-chan racer PewDiePie edition
headphones are you gonna be a virgin or
a Chang I'm gonna leave that answer up
to you because I already know you
[ __ ] virgins next mean guys that's
what they're trading this is the worst
meme of all time but I still love it so
much why
this hamster it's my last brain cell
like who filmed this and why why does
that ball really about the geek hey go
ahead country and I'd wait oh here not
be well afro Hannah my current mood
right now oh yeah it's so cute and
horrible looking yeah memes are just
getting worse every year
show them hamster me what the Frick
same energy next up we have the another
armlet related min isn't that crazy -
and then one week like what the heck was
up with arms lately okay so it's the one
from Spyder MERS or he put the arms girl
and I think the problem with this meme
is that it's just not funny guys explain
to me what's funny about this I was
raised here
zucchini oh my whoa hey hey Jesus Christ
I don't get this mean it only works as a
cross over that mean was so bad set me
down at least six thousand years
humanity will never recover
I'm tired of dick you know we were
looking so promising this year big
chunga's that's how Mafia works so many
epic means but now the system has gone
too far and I'm so frickin tired of
pretending to be okay with it and why do
I still do this fake Swedish accent
who's never funny we have time for bonus
meme everybody holy freaking moly
gorgonzola Jesus blesses this video
himself meme review has 2 bonus memes in
a row holy heck okay we're gonna have to
pull out something really nice something
really very epic he will never have a
girlfriend I don't know if you guys have
seen his mean look it's Super Mario he
will never have a girlfriend and he's
like its child a buff and then it's like
dude I bet there's a PewDiePie version
of it where I look like super ugly and
then it's like damn she will never
become Marge Simpson Oh
what the Frick dude so proud do you want
a gay kiss okay
there's a like commercial an action
everyone finally something positive has
happening in the meme community you will
never be bawling that's what we would
say in 2018 but in 2019 we should be
bowling look at that
stop Haiti he will never become Bart
Simpson they said point proven the
actual liberal
man she's just a male oppa fantasy with
that personality girl a more realistic
character to identify Anna
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dude shook
whoa wow she is so freaking cute
everyone watching Harry Potter
oh god oh Sh oh Sh Blair Scooby Doo
he will never be bawling damn son he's
be bawling fat dunks and hopes and stuff
okay this has been meme review I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode we're
trying out something new here so I hope
you guys support this series by smashing
like and subscribing now I don't know if
you guys have heard about this but this
set website called t-series it looks
like they're gonna take over my channel
pretty soon like I'm not like paying
attention to that kind of stuff but if
you like want to subscribe so that we
can beat them I think that wouldn't be
pretty cool just to like show the power
of the army of meme reviews there's my
fellow meemers so yeah I don't know like
just subscribe or whatever I don't
really
it doesn't like matter